go to sleep in a chocolate bar or a can
of sardines and an infectious-disease
stress ball that you can squish it's
episode 16 of loot are you tired of
wimpy straws that make you look like a
loser
we'll grab faint geeks food grade
titanium straw it tears into fruit like
metal justice keep being awesome with
this mirror decal that makes you look
like the star of a press conference
or these decals you can use to let
guests accessorize themselves by
standing just the right way keep a stash
of temporary stash twos handy to quickly
turn your finger into what you must
stash then lay back on your hamburger
beanbag it's not cheap but come on a
diamond shaped beanbag that's almost as
classy as liqueur scented soaps your
butt is not clean until it smells like a
whiskey sour also on Etsy are these
adorable Punk kitties Hank emailed me
about his friend makes them and he says
each one is handmade and completely
unique there will never be another one
like it
speaking of email these Air Swimmers
also wound up in my inbox
remote-controlled floating balloons you
can scare cats with but if you're sick
of emailing you're gonna love today's
briefing snail mail my email is a
project started by Ivan Cash all you
have to do is send an email with the
recipients address to snail mail my
email at gmail.com by August 15th a team
of volunteers will then handwrite your
message and mail it to who you say write
your own awesome messages in this
notebook where instead of blank paper
you're given blank New York City walls
and trucks that your notes and doodles
can deface as a final escape for modern
technology transform your iPhone 4 into
an old leather book and then enter the
future with this amazing levitron I
found on bat 19 it can hold objects up
to 12 ounces and automatically adjusts
when they move or change weight here's a
wine stopper that makes the bottle look
like a message in a bottle but if you
prefer your potent potables quantifiable
use this glass which has markings
designating exact servings of spear
beer and wine Beastie Boys action
figures a spoon action figure a
miniature camera that's a USB flash
drive and a flash drive that's fresh
beans can be fun when they come in a can
water this and when the seed grows it'll
sprout with a message written on it if
you live in or near London I'm gonna be
there this weekend at summer in the city
it's an awesome get-together for cool
people and cool youtubers and if you can
make it I'll be there Vsauce unite
speaking of Vsauce are you subscribe to
Vsauce too yet if not you're missing out
on knowledge there's a brand-new episode
of mind blow over there right now so
what are you waiting for click here to
go watch it and as always thanks for
watching